hello
what's your favorite scary movie
ghostface is back and scary as ever
now's the time to make a new screen
because we have a special story to tell
that connects the legacy cast members
with a new cast into the world of
woodsboro
my character sam becomes the target of
the ghostface killer who is this someone
who knows your little secret
she seeks dewey for help
dewey he's pulled back in because he's
still got a huge heart and really wants
to help sydney she's moved on in her
life it's happening
three attacks so far
and then chaos ensues
it's just the perfect mix of new energy
and also keeping in what made it so
special in the first place i don't think
it's exactly what people are expecting
there's things that happen in this that
are kind of shocking i still can't
believe it
i've been through this a lot whoever
this is is gonna keep coming for you so
so i want you to help us kill him
so many twists and turns who's the
killer who's not we don't know
sounds about right
[Applause]
you